i look at this wall at all what is it
what is it giving you
honestly it's goals it's inspiration you
know because this is clearly a passion
and a labor of love for you but you've
turned it into like a thriving business
you know no idea this would be happening
but you've also shared it too you
brought people in and you know the
conspiracy palette launch wasn't that
long ago
and obviously so much has changed
between you and shane um
you know what did you think of shane's
departure from youtube um and where do
things stand with you too now
hi hi
we're still really great friends yeah um
i know he's not very active on social
media lately he is i'm really excited
you know i think he took a really long
break um
and i'm proud of him for doing a lot of
self-reflection as well
those are the two words of the day right
but um he's doing really great we're
really
great friends we always will be um and
we're so proud of our collection yeah
that's crazy how
the collection happened and then the
pandemic hit
so came at the right time it did it
really really did it was wild
i need to take a time out and all of
this has been
way way way way bigger than i think
anyone could have
ever imagined hi all james here um
i'm currently traveling abroad and just
woke up but i wanted to sit down
and make a video addressing everything
that's going on right now
without getting into too many details
just like rapid fire quickly yeah
where does your relationship stand with
tattoo westbrook right now oh okay
uh zero zero no relationship
relationship james charles
zero zero so i haven't i haven't seen
either of them in probably two years now
yeah and that's probably been
the best for you mentally i think so
yeah to kind of step away from the
beauty community and
everything that was happening that's
right carol absolutely you want to talk
about pride month
obviously pride month i i mean pride i
feel like has evolved so much over the
years
and now things are opening up they are
they're open i know we need community
you know i'm curious what does pride
mean to you these days oh i love that
question it really means
freedom and really accepting who you are
and being able to
be yourself and i think that's always
been my biggest message um growing up i
never felt like i fit in and pride was
not
um really prominent and i'm from orange
county and so there wasn't a lot of that
so
i would escape and go to la when i was
younger and find all the cool
gay clubs and people and shows and just
feel accepted for the first time
do you remember your first pride i do
what was it i'm
okay oh she's she's totally incalculable
she's aging herself right now no no
it wasn't california it was in um long
beach okay oh my god i've been surprised
long beach pride is but you ready for
this 2003.
okay so what was a 2003 pride in long
beach like um
it was actually really loud and proud
and long beach has always been i think a
really cool hub for the lgbt community
especially in california yeah um and i
remember just feeling like
wow there's people like there's guys in
makeup there's drag queens there's so
many different walks of life that you
don't normally just see going out to the
grocery store
yeah which that was me being a guy
makeup like
wow there's no one else like me so to go
to a place where everyone just
was full of love and no one judged me
meant i think more than me than i ever
knew back then
and now that there's going to be
hopefully more in-person pride events
this year i can imagine
the little babies out there experiencing
their first prize and i think that's so
special yeah it is what advice do you
have for the
queer youth out there especially those
who might be struggling finding their
place
in this world i think that's a that's a
really good one i think
for me specifically i had to be patient
which is really hard right and find
people that really accept you for who
you are
um and i think that's so important yeah
um so
be strong um never change who you are
because so many people tried to tell me
oh you shouldn't do this you shouldn't
do that you shouldn't wear makeup this
is too feminine or this is too bad and i
think it was so important to just stick
to who i really wanted to always be yeah
and i think that everyone should do that
as well look what happens when you live
your truth
okay fully actually yeah
a hundred percent
[Music]